that's pretty awesome thanks John that's
great I didn't get it anything that's a
great story I don't think you got it
babe what not John are you being - no no
that's like one of those things that you
moved up to LA to like you know be a
part or something like that or here's
temp so I said what a [ __ ] thought if
I had the money and the means you would
I would hire you just to be around I
think he's actually he's serious John
because he says there's something about
you that makes him happy it's not even
just you you don't I don't respect and
you know what I don't respect you I
think I'd that you because if you want
to think that I respect you and I don't
want to be on I respect you enough to be
honest you an insider info yeah this is
why I know he respects you he said the
other time when the last podcast that
were you were here he was like I think I
have a problem because when I'm speaking
I only play I don't play to the whole
room I'm only playing - John nah yeah I
said about his opinion yeah I only care
about your opinion I believe that when
your little Filipinos they don't respect
that no they have a good twinkle I think
you have you know that twinkle guy goop
thing that you do right where you know
you're like in the right direction right
I I love it and encourages me and I love
this guy I love everything about him and
if I had enough money and I was if I was
Joe Rogan it was cooler yeah I would
give you the world
but I can't give you [ __ ] those words
it's enough it's enough out of you if
you know what I regret even saying that
[ __ ] [ __ ] good go now dude right
now I fed that little tiny monster
inside your heart all right don't don't
get carried away I love you
now you know what I'm doing right now
what people are saying on the internet
that I am a fake alpha male what is that
where's people saying this all on the
Internet I know the internet but like
directly to you thing is a fake alpha
yes they it's some guy a couple of times
not just one guy couple guys have said
yeah we don't like the way he MOC alpha
males the room when he's really just a
follower you
tries to be an alpha male and it's like
[ __ ] this is my clan this is my tribe
or right lead wolf absolutely this is
yeah we might not have a good pack
there's just saying though that the
loudest person in the room usually has
the least to say wait I did the victory
thing like this you smart I tried that
when I did this I go didn't feel right
she tricked you so she did you trick me
or I think it's a good thing the way she
said it the way you said it was bad I
don't like the way you said it say it
again do-over tell out let's rewind
rewind rewind it the loudest person in
the room has the least to say yeah okay
that's not good it didn't feel good that
was it goes to me [ __ ] you babe
alright you're right I have nothing to
say I'm a fakie